all right guys
bang bang i've got lisa here with me uh
thank you so much for doing this
pleasure to be here absolutely all right
let's jump right into
your background um you have a very very
cool story
and have had one major exit and
hopefully you're on your way to the
second major exit
as an entrepreneur but what did you do
kind of before you started building
companies
yeah um so i'm one of those accidental
entrepreneurs
um i was always the irritated engineer
in you know a technology company that
thought you know management and the
sales people were always doing the wrong
thing by the customer and i could do it
way better than anybody
else um small side story uh
eight years later after i started hyper
wallet i actually called some of my old
bosses and apologized to them
because then i knew how hard it was um
but the
you know the background really is um so
i was a working engineer in
aviation information systems and made
the switch to
payments 20 years ago when online
shopping became a thing and i took that
job simply because i was interested in
the technology you know
internet databases um and really quickly
i became intrigued by online commerce
and the impedance in things like
international payments
uh and the truth is it was 1999 we were
all partying like it was 1999
and we thought hey we can do it better
we're not going to let ignorance get
stand in our way and we're going to
found a company
so that's the honest back story of how i
you know founded a payments company um
and then it was a long inco
inculcation into like how the industry
works and how to find a value prop
within it
got it and so uh that business was hyper
wallet
um you end up scaling it and paypal
eventually bought that business for
about 400 million dollars
my understanding maybe just tell us kind
of what was the original idea you guys
had and they kind of how did you
scale that product uh and kind of build
something valuable enough for uh for a
large company like paypal to come in and
sure so uh the story of hyperwallet is
twofold one
under capitalized and a bunch of
engineers building products
looking for a market so really
we you know hyperwall was an 18-year
overnight success story
and what we built that was really
interesting was something that in the
industry is now called cross-border ach
but the ability to do compliant
and very cost-effective low-value
cross-border payments so you know any
idiot
can compliantly send 300 000 from the
united states to france
and take a you know couple hundred or
thousand dollar commission for the
foreign exchange and fees along the way
but if you want to send 300 from
the united states to france for a
business paying out a 1099 worker for
example
that's actually not easy to do at a
price point
and a compliance level so that's the
platform
that hyperwallet slowly built over the
years
was the ability to do take advantage of
local in-country low-cost clearing
networks so we slowly built
a global network of networks if you will
but the business was still really small
and so when it became
more valuable was around 2010
when you know a sales person a sales
executive actually joined and said look
instead of
trying to point this at individual
consumers or point this at cor
at banks let's point this at corporates
that really need to
pay many many hundreds of thousands of
1099 workers
so that was the direct selling industry
i think mary kay herbalife those kind of
companies had real
problem and ultimately what we were
competing against
was checks in fedex packages
right and then what really provided the
tailwind for that business
was the um you know evolution of the
marketplace in marketplace like
businesses
and so it was a low slow
burn slowly you know we had bootstrap
and made it profitable because we had to
we found a vertical niche that
ultimately became more valuable as a
horizontal play
and what was your biggest lessons
learned as you kind of built that
business right because it sounds like uh
you kind of went through all the ups the
downs and and uh the excitement
and uh the the tough times what were the
biggest lessons you took away
um well one is as an entrepreneur um
that you know as a product focused
entrepreneur
you know you shouldn't it's not sales is
not bad
and revenue is not bad and you know
finding your market is not bad and
actually servicing the customer is
is not bad um so i learned the
difference between marketing and sales
which is a tough tough lesson for an
engineer to actually comprehend
um but the other you know more relevant
to financial services
is it's you know building layer upon
layer of what's there
is okay trying to drill right down and
build something
brand new and i call it like fighting
city hall
in the industry um is a bit of a mug's
game and unless you have the ability to
raise billions of dollars
you know that's kind of not a battle you
want to be in so that was my other
lesson
yeah and then talk a little bit about um
kind of when the company actually was
acquired
uh was that hey we think that they can
take it further and farther
uh you know with us um is that something
hey i wanted to go work on another
thing like kind of what was the impetus
and really the idea being
uh there's a lot of founders who listen
to this and uh they dream of one day
having their company acquired right or
taking it public and so how did you kind
of go through the
evaluation of what's actually due before
you did that transaction
um yeah let me preface it that i
actually stepped down from an operating
role in 2015 so i was still on the board
and still
very much involved but not as a
management and not sort of stewarding
the business
but what i can say is it was time to
provide liquidity
to our shareholders so that absolutely
was
part of the motivation and when you
think about it we were profitable
uh profitable and growing but within
hyper wallet providing pay outs there
was
only so much the business could do and
grow and with the regulatory complexity
the opportunity to find a bigger
platform
that can merit in payments marry pay in
and payouts
right so think about from paypal's
perspective
putting braintree and hyperwallet
together to compete against the likes of
the stripes and the audience
of the world that are you know coming up
that was very exciting so to broaden the
applicability of the platform um
you know and be part of something big
and
and see that see that baby that we built
really
continue to grow beyond what we could do
it sounds trite but that actually was
part of it
no that makes uh makes complete sense
and then once you decide
hey i'm gonna uh go do this again and go
bash my head against the wall and build
another company
uh did you have an idea as to what you
wanted to build or did you kind of make
the decision
uh let me build a company and then i'll
go find what idea i want to work on
um it's really interesting this the
genesis story of 5 spin is completely
different than
like bottle of chardonnay and hey this
is a great idea
of hyperwallet because i did have the
benefit of 18 years in the industry
so i called phi span a very intentional
business
i literally sat in my basement for a
year
thinking about different business ideas
because this is the one truth about
about founders if you have asked me in
2012
if i would start another company let
alone a financial services company
i would tell you only an idiot would
start a payments company
only like you know a super idiot would
try and do this again
but you know we have a very very
selective memory and all the highs and
lows of running a business
you forget all the terrible lows when
you want to shoot yourself in the head
and you only remember all those great
times right
so but but feisman is very very
intentional
and i certainly took some of the
market observations from the hyperwall
at time
and a couple things were one that all
the hype in financial services
is in the retail side because that's
what everybody knows you
know what it's like for you to use a
credit card or for you to use apple pay
right you know when you get irritated
about
you know your bank's online banking so
that's where all the hype is and a lot
of the attention but i
i really believe that there's huge
opportunities to make the world better
for
businesses um and the second thing i
knew
being an intentional start to fi span
was i didn't want to
compete against banks i fundamentally
had this thesis
that banks have superior payments
products superior cash management
services
superior loans because they have a lower
cost of capital like just
you know just think about the
fundamental underlying
attributes but they have real really
really
struggle with you know that
quote-unquote delightful user experience
um so i literally sat there and i was
like you know there is there an
opportunity to introduce a
company and a business model into the
market that's sort of the opposite of
plans
where you're not aggregating banks for
third parties to own the customers
you're you're aggregating the end points
to allow
banks to better service their customers
so
that's the genesis story of phi span a
forgot the bad times
uh b had enough um you just wanted to do
it again
and see there was just so much
opportunity yeah and so this is a really
um interesting uh kind of framework you
provided of like there's plenty of
people out there who said hey
we're going to aggregate all the banks
and then allow the third parties to have
that relationship with the customer
you essentially are doing something
opposite right kind of taking the
uh the thing that everyone sees value in
and it's kind of been funding for a
while
and you flipped it why was that where
you wanted to go did you have kind of a
contrarian view
saying that you know the other people
just don't see this opportunity
uh was it a skill set or an experience
that you had but like how
did you identify that where maybe others
haven't spent a lot of time
uh well so there were some actual um
data points conversations with cfos and
treasurers back in my hyper wallet day
where what hyper wallet had done yes
with this
fantastic low-cost mass b2c service
but and we'd exposed ourselves through
apis to be in the cool kids club
but we'd done one more thing which is
our engineers had
integrated our products and our apis
into our customers business system of
record these are big publicly traded
billion dollar companies
and that fact engendered a lot of love
and when i would go back and talk
to my customers they would say hey can
you provide us b2b payment services
can you provide us with cash management
services can you provide us with foreign
exchange
and i feel like why i'm just this tiny
little
under capitalized company why would you
even offer me and so
what they'd said is look i'm highly
banked
but what my banks offer me is a file
spec and now i need to go out and hire
someone to integrate it with my
workflows
and then i have a separate process and
then my internal controls are shot and
then i have an
additional audit cost um
so that was the specific
insight right it wasn't like i decided
it's
very clever to have a contrarian view to
the market it was
that there was sufficient pain points by
by corporates that they were willing to
engage with third parties
for like fund what i call fundamental
transactional services
and so like quite frankly it was just
opportunistic i thought
look um i don't i don't want to build
something from scratch
but if i can arm banks to really service
that
need that's better for the customer
better for the banks
yeah that makes a lot of sense and so
talk a little bit about um
kind of what was the first product you
built and kind of what does that
product uh or product suite look like
today yeah
so fundamentally what we we like to say
at five spin
um we bring business banking into the
customer context
and what we mean by that is like from
the customer's perspective it's about
jobs to be done
not a bank product to be used right so
i want to keep current with my overseas
customers
i don't want to send a wire right i want
to forecast my cash
i don't want to log into online banking
to view my balances
so in practice what we do is we embed
commercial banking services within other
applications
and the first and most important
experience
is embedding inside accounting and erp
applications
so we bring those bank services in
context
easiest way to think of it is by example
i'm inside my erp i've gone through my
workflow to approve a vendor invoice
i just want to click and have this
vendor invoice paid
i don't want to care whether it's like
ach check print
wire right i just click it's going to be
paid i know which
bank account it's going to be out of
tomorrow when all like the magic has
happened
that object is going to be automatically
updated in my erp
all the track and trace information is
there
open banking apis you know host to host
connectivity
can make that all happen making that all
happen seamlessly without the customer
worrying about it
is what we do so there's a whole bunch
of
um kind of magic that happens and i
always describe
the type of business that you're in is
uh you want the customer to know about
you when you're
selling them to use the product and then
when they're using the product uh
you almost don't want them to know
you're there right because you're
basically
kind of magically doing all of these
things that just make their life
easier and part of this is there's these
two
key ideas right so there's open banking
and then there's embedded banking and
maybe we can talk through
open banking first um what does that
mean
and kind of how is that playing out in
just fintech in general then how are you
guys actually interfacing with open
banking
yeah so um open
banking you know means different things
to different people you know it can be
regulatory driven but by and large what
it means
is an obligation of a financial
institution
to make its customers data and services
accessible
to third-party applications and
endpoints right so
it's where the bank will expose a
security and authentication paradigm
that somebody else can come to
whether it's uh you know pim right so
personal finance pfm personal financial
manager application
and i can aggregate all my bank accounts
inside this third-party application
open banking requires the bank
to say yes to that third-party inquiry
to receive my balance and transaction
history in different jurisdictions it
sometimes
it actually almost always is a
regulatory initiative right like
bank thousand must um so
what open banking brings to the industry
is a set of
application apis that developers and
third parties can consume
to make these things happen uh at
fizeban we think
embedded banking is an outcome
of this technology this api
interconnectivity in a permissioned and
secure way
but embedded banking can be a result of
open banking
or it can be a result of like an
industry initiative so
we happen to service at 5 span north
american pre
and primarily u.s financial institutions
where there is no
obligated open banking so
we integrate with our banks in a trust
model
and then create those apis for the bank
so i'm not sure if that answered your
question open banking is the set of
technologies and
regulatory obligation embedded banking
is
the embodiment of that for the benefit
of customers
got it and so the open banking aspect is
really just providing
way more connectivity between all of
this
infrastructure these organizations um
and the way i've thought about it and
you're the expert so you're going to
correct me if i'm wrong here is kind of
what the internet did
to uh connect organizations people
uh infrastructure et cetera really open
banking's just doing that in a kind of a
single
niche vertical of finance banking right
it really is this idea of like how do we
use these digital tools to
provide much more connectivity and
reduce friction across uh
everything yeah right i can go back i
can
see you and trump you on that analogy
all right let's hear it
i can go back another generation and
talk about odbc
right which was uh like database you
know open database
whatever it was like connect so this was
a technology open banking is like a
technology and
concept that enables greater access to
an asset that can you know provide value
to
the the owners or users of that asset
whether or not a specific database
provider whether oracle
endorsed odbc and opened up its database
through this new paradigm was its own
internal decision
right and your analogy of the internet
enabled
this much greater you know access
connectivity
interoperability it would be up to an
individual
industry whether it wanted to offer
services and products online
that's where we are with open banking
right now the promise of it is huge and
enormous
banks are trying to figure out whether
and how they want to participate in this
and
quote unquote what's in it for them
and then the idea of this kind of
embedded banking
uh that really is more of um
leaning into this theme that like it
feels like every technology company
is somehow becoming a fintech right i
mean it seems like every single
business is in some manner trying to
incorporate
uh some financial service right
yeah and so i would argue that that
doesn't mean every single business is
trying to become a fintech
that embedded banking allows every
single business
to um to make
use of a fintech service for the
betterment of
its product and service delivery now
some do
want to become fintechs so um
an accounting system like quickbooks
that wants to
offer a payment service and monetize it
that's one strategy
but an accounting system that just wants
to provide the best
account you know the best experience for
its customer not necessarily monetize it
is another example of you know somebody
who's going to benefit from
open banking and so what does this mean
for
the banks themselves right i think that
we we've kind of um
historically there was a a line in the
sand and it would be like uh
you know a a kindergarten teacher saying
okay all the banks on the left side and
all of the technology companies on the
right side
uh i don't think you can do that anymore
because that line is very very blurred
so those traditional banks what what
happens to them or do they are they
actually beneficiaries of all of those
massive beneficiaries and that was you
know when we go back to the like
founding thesis of feistband is i always
saw
open banking and you know the api
economy as
just an enormous opportunity for banks
not a threat
but everyone's worried about being
disintermediated right so if my customer
is using my payment service and it's
initiate it's not my brand they're not
clicking on like my button somebody
else's
that's scary but what i fundamentally
believed is
open banking has the possibility of
bringing
as much actionable but new data into the
bank domain
as it does to take data out of the bank
domain and put it in the
you know hands of third parties specific
example again
is imagine with connectivity to a
customer's accounting system
in a permissioned way bank could now
have
real time and continuous access to
that businesses open receivables income
statement
balance sheet and now instead of
inferring the best customers to lend to
and you know making a guess at the
underwriting
imagine if with permission of the
business
the bank could shave a few basis points
off of a loan offer
um make the lending experience
absolutely seamless
and that treasurer just looks at his
forward forecast and says yes
i'll take this two million dollars of
working capital starting from here to
hear it you know
and then loan servicing that's the
promise and so
these other end points and these other
applications that will be
embedding financial services in them if
you take the in
the data and information out of them it
allows the bank to provide
a better product and a better service to
its customers
so one of the things that um
over the years absolutely shocked me
about anything banking and finance
related
was how non-predictive the
technologies were everything was pretty
much
counting what was happening facilitating
things that are happening now
but it was very hard i think and some of
that was due to lack of technology some
was due to lack of
data some was due lack of just time and
energy spent building it
uh on more like the predictive analytics
and kind of using what we know today to
tell us what's going to happen in the
future
it feels like this open banking embedded
banking
kind of busts down that wall and creates
a world where there's so much data and
there's so much technology and so many
integrations that
there really can be and maybe there is
being a very
big rise in a lot of these predictive
technologies
um i completely agree with you but
what's interesting is
i that's where i think this theme of new
kind of data companies
is what is the next next thing
okay so today yeah so today everybody's
trying to act
on um you know
these breadcrumbs that we leave
all around the world right and a bank is
a bank or somebody else is trying to say
hey which are the best customers to lend
to
based on the linked what's happening
with this business on linkedin how many
people they're hiring what they've
bought et cetera and
what i think is the future and what
we've based
our company on is what i'm calling like
the custodial age
of data and what i mean by that is that
the new kind of data opportunities
will morph from their current state
which is this this massive
amount of side effect information that
you then need to apply
ai on to to you know make sense of
um you know she read an article on
business process automation
right and so let's feed her ads for the
for every crm and workflow app
out there there for the next 12 months
i'm currently experiencing that so it's
one of my pet peeves right
instead of feistband we think that the
most interesting opportunities
will arise from the intentional sharing
of actual data and actual intent
with bounded and enforced usage rights
around that data
and so when you talk about like the ai
implications
right instead of having it being
artificial information
what about having it being actual
information
um and you know the best predictor of
the future is actually the past
right um so the most interesting new
platform businesses
you know in my opinion won't be the ones
that are amassing the most data but but
instead they'll be the platforms
that provide the best access
data owner control and watermarking
services
to the data exchanges that matter right
and the data exchanges that matter i
believe are
you know between a bank and its
customers and okay so let's
dig a little bit deeper on that because
i think it's a really interesting view
of the world
uh historically let's take you know
social media companies finance companies
all these different types of companies
uh they basically had a couple of
different assets
uh most financial investors would look
at
how much revenue do you have what's your
profitability how many users do you have
all that kind of stuff inside of the
companies and literally i worked at
facebook for two years so i know
uh the more access information you have
the better you can make the product the
more personalized the more contextual
the longer somebody will stay the more
ads you can serve kind of
you know one of the assets is definitely
the more information i get the user to
give me
uh the better this is for us as a
company
right it's kind of one of the the key
tenets what it sounds like you're
talking about and that's true
to banks and others as well right it's
kind of the more information
the better what you're talking about is
actually almost
flipping the model and saying no the
winners of tomorrow are going to be the
people who don't
look at it as uh from the corporation
seat instead they look at it from the
user seat
and they say what can we as a business
do to empower this user to have the best
experience the most privacy the most
efficiency
kind of all of that and a lot of it's
actually going to be not to hold on to
the data it's going to be to give the
user the data to give them permissioning
to give them
all sorts of tools that maybe
historically they haven't had
uh because incentives weren't aligned
between the corporation and uh and the
end user is that fair to say
um that's not only fair that's probably
a better way of saying it than than i do
at my pitch so i'll invite you to
my next sales pitch no no no you you do
a fantastic job
um but in all seriousness like when i
you know as i talked about you know
founding
fastband sitting there quietly in my
basement googling away
i believe that the value of
fi span to our customers the banks and
ultimately to allow them to provide
value to their customers
is precisely because i
as fi span assert no ownership
or usage rights over any of the data
that traverses my network right so um
and the apps i built on behalf of the
bank so our jpmorgan chase
you know uh erp extension isn't branded
fi spam
it's it's branded jpmor it's a it's a
service of jpmorgan chase
to their customer but nonetheless if
it's a
product i'm building i'm building
permissions
inside of it right and if when you click
and install this extension
and you say i agree to share the vendor
file my vendor file with the bank
it's not for the purpose of the bank
marketing to those vendors it's for the
purposes of the bank
to provide me with a better accounts
payable risk management experience or
something like that
so that's just our policy and we think
that that's going to build value in the
future and we are
an example of a new kinds of
you know data platform but there'll be
many more
other kinds of examples of that got it
and then in terms
of um that
from a product building standpoint
it do you have to have full end-to-end
encryption
so that not only do you not have
ownership or usage of the data but you
actually can't see it
or is this a situation where uh you kind
of can't really
do the job that the products intended to
right if you can't see the data so it's
kind of like this
hybrid model of you don't want ownership
you don't want um uh usage
it's more of just like a permission that
the user told me to do x with their data
i go do that job and then i don't do
anything else until they tell me to do
something else right
yeah yeah um
we're not there yet and um
so i i see i
absolutely see what you're saying um but
it just
happens that our business model is we're
both a
you know technology outsource and
servicing outsource component of the
bank
so in order to service the clients we
need to see that data
yep and that's what that would be my
expectation in that
it's different for like and for those
that are listening who may not
who may think that we're in the weeds
here for a second uh take facebook for
example
uh if lisa and i are both on facebook
and i send her a message
uh other than for advertising purposes
there is no need for facebook to be able
to read
what message i sent to lisa or what
message she sends back to me
so you can have kind of full end to end
the encryption where only lisa can read
it or only i can read it
facebook doesn't need to see that now
facebook would like to see it because
they'd like to target us on advertising
whatever
but for the intent and purposes of what
we're trying to do in communications
and encryption makes a lot of sense when
it comes to this information though
you can imagine if you interacted with
your bank
but they couldn't see the amount that
you were sending they really can't
kind of do their job right so there's
certain pieces of information obviously
that they need
uh which would make sense in this
situation yeah so
um we where we're also
not there yet from a technology
perspective
is um you know there's there's oauth
there's all sorts of encryption
tokenization
that technology exists but i haven't yet
seen an embodiment of
the what i'm calling watermarking of
data which is like
having its intended permissions
around its usage being enforced
um end to end so that technology doesn't
exist but we're starting to
within the industry have discourses
about it so whoever invents that i think
will be
and it's not going to be me but that
will be another example of a very
valuable
technology and business to be introduced
and is this the idea so
um there's a lot of people myself
included who
who believes that kind of every stock
bond currency and commodity will get
digitized in the future and so let's
take
equity for example uh it would be
awesome
if the equity was in some sort of token
or digital format
and it could prevent a non-accredited
investor from buying
an asset it's not supposed to from an
accredited investor right and kind of
it's almost like this um uh
self-governance
through an automated technology because
the asset itself it has
rules and uh kind of regulations coded
into it sounds like that's what you're
talking about here
it's exactly what i'm like a different
analogy but it's like the data that
traverses again we'll use that example
of
um if i'm a business and i'm going to
share my list of all my vendors with my
bank
right and the purpose is to help me
reduce accounts payable fraud
right it's that purpose of the data
right and so what i'm talking about is
when that data is now
conveyed to the bank today at 5 span i
can
pass along those permissions but i can't
enforce them i can't
like once that data is at the bank um
except contractually like they know what
they're supposed to do
but the actual owner of that data
today i'm not providing him or her with
an audit trail of exactly where that
data
went and what it was used for after
it's gone out of my system that's not a
technology that i'm going to build but i
would love
to see it because once we have something
like that as a standard
then the opportunity for data owners
to actually decide how much of you
to really have control and confidence
and be able to monitor choose to use
facebook
or or or not right um to me that's
interesting i mean i'll hopefully be
done by then but
absolutely and i think that will happen
at some point it's just
to your point who built the technology
and kind of how do they implement it
um first right is it is it equities is
it currency something like that
uh i would be um absolutely berated on
the internet if i didn't take the time
while i had you to talk a little bit
about
digital currencies uh you spend all day
dealing with
large banks bank customers kind of fit
financial technology
what have you seen from a viability
standpoint whether it's
you know a u.s digital dollar a digital
euro type thing so kind of a central
bank back digital currency
there's the private currencies like the
libras that have been kind of thrown out
those ideas
uh or even into the cryptocurrencies um
like the bitcoins and things like that
is there conversation about that in kind
of the world that you operate in
is it people are aware of it they don't
really care and don't talk about it just
give us
an idea of kind of what you've seen so
far on the ground yeah in my simple
world
businesses aren't asking i'm a really
simple person
at hyperwallet you know we were
all about enabling different sorts of
you know payee directed if you wanted to
companies sending you 300
you want to have that direct deposit in
your bank cool you can do that under
your control if you want to pick up cash
at western union
cool you can do that under your control
so
when digital currencies in bitcoin
ethereum first came out
i mean i was and still like a fangirl
just because the technology the prospect
of it
so i really thought that hyperwallet
ourselves should become an endpoint
um but this is going back to our
beginning this is after 2012 when we're
quote unquote a real company that was
making real money
um so not just a bunch of engineers
building the next cool thing
so i actually went to my head of
development i said i think that we
should become an endpoint at least on
ripple because it's you know
it's um you know in the cool kids club
it's bank last strike
um we went out and serviced our
customers and they were like
okay we have no interest in it
um so fast forward to now where i am at
phi span
um i'm trying to build applications that
you know move the peanut forward a
little bit
for end customers and to be honest
i'm not excited about digital currency
for you know b2b
payments um i've never thought that the
rails
were the problem it's always been the
end points and those consumptive
applications
so i fundamentally don't think the world
needs another
payment rail um you know taking aside
the
political view of unstable currencies
and you know bad governments and
everything else
um where i'm most excited
about distributed ledger technology
is around things like
taking massive costs out of
regulatory burdens um doing things like
encrypting your kyc file on a customer
as a bank putting that on some like
ethereum like block
whatever whatever chain you want and
then having
you know only permissioned and you know
who's opening that little secret package
and why
um to me this can take enormous cost
and operational burden out of things
like sending a
wire from the united states
to thailand
where a bank today has to have a direct
correspondent relationship it's slow
it's horrible imagine
if you could just put this delivery
request
onto an ethereum block onto some
blockchain
any any delivery point in thailand can
pick it up and say yes i'm going to
deliver this money to this
you know endpoint if and only if i get a
regulatory
hit meaning like the thai regulator says
whoa
whoa that's on my kyb watch list
then i'll pick up this package unencrypt
it you'll know about it
the customer will know about it and the
purpose of us
accessing this data will be known so
long-winded explanation but that's what
i'm most excited about in financial
services
for blockchains and distributed ledgers
how far away are we from that
um there's a number of initiatives
actually started
uh and you know again it all gets mired
down into the business model
uh i know for a fact that you know jp
morgan chase has started something
exactly like that
um swift has their own initiative around
something exactly like that
um and what's interesting is banks are
getting in of course i immediately
it's like oh i want to participate right
just because it's like
it's not directly related to what i do
but it is like sexy and interesting so
some aspects of like the kernel of being
like a nerdy engineer
um never truly leave you um
but we are so the answer is we're close
to having services like that
actually we're not disclosed services
like that are in beta now
what now has to happen is the various
people have to
you know think about their position in
the market and how do they want to play
on somebody else's sandbox because
even though these things are open and
owned by nobody uh
they're still perceived to have you know
my competitor is behind that one do i
want to play
but it is exciting and it is coming got
it
what do you kind of foresee as the uh
future path uh for the company right
as you've kind of built five spin like
where are you
headed um and
maybe not what the finish line is but
kind of what's like the big milestone
that you say when we get there like
that'll have accomplished the goal yeah
um
i actually can answer that good it's
when
there are applications being built not
by fi span
that are actually delivering value so we
want to become
an open banking uh we want to support
api programs and developer programs and
i want to have
as delightful a developer experience as
strike does
right where any you know bob and joe
mckenzie can
be in their basement have a great idea
for servicing
sign up and start actually providing
value
like on day one um
when i have to answer your question when
i have 500 applications
interoperating with my banks and they're
not built by phi span
then um i'll i'll be a happy person
i think that's a fair way to uh to look
at it
i wrap up every interview with the same
two questions for everyone
the first is what is the most important
book that you've ever read
so you can tell that i didn't actually
see that um
okay okay it was actually a biography of
now
oh explain that why is that your answer
that's a great answer
um well first of all i'm trying to think
all the books i read i was really into
different biographies of different
despots
the uh
the overlay of you know history and
individuals and death spots
coming together and you know
cultural revolution so
i just found it really interesting i
didn't find it informative as
to how i want to comport myself um
but that was the most influential clinic
that's a great answer your first person
ever say that one that's great um
i have one more question it's a little
bit more fun and then you actually get
to ask me one question to
end it but my question is about aliens
are you a believer
or a non-believer total believer why
uh because of the because the
because it's infinite and the concept is
like it's it's
simple math the answer is simple math
i have yet to have anyone who has an
engineering background come on and not
answer
of course it's just math
like i always tell people the two
answers i get that are most
common is yes of course it's just math
or probability or some version of that
uh and then the people who say no uh
will say well i haven't seen one so
until i see one they're not real
like okay um if you have asked will i
you know will we see evidence of it in
my life
in my lifetime my answer is absolutely
not but
because you think they're too far away
we don't have the technology or because
yeah because we're not advanced yet
enough yet yeah i think that's a fair
uh fair answer uh all right you get to
ask me one question to uh to finish up
what do you got for me
my question is why are your listeners um
so focused on bitcoin and um
you know distributed currencies why is
that a focus of your podcast
yeah um for a theme so uh
i pretty much am very selfish when it
comes to the podcast i just talk about
things that i find interesting uh and if
people want to listen then
great if they don't uh too bad for them
it's kind of always been my approach and
i'm pretty transparent about that
so uh you know you end up finding people
who have similar interests or they find
you
right um and on bitcoin uh the two
things that
uh i think when somebody asked me why
right cause everyone always asks me what
like what is it how does it work
it's all that kind of but like the why
am i personally interested in it
i think that uh there are
significant and i mean like
world-changing
implications when you get to the point
of uh a currency no longer being a
weapon against the people
and what i mean by that is you know take
wealth inequality for example
the number one cause of wealth
inequality in the world is uh
inflation so through uh you know the
lack of inflation-adjusted wage
contracts or
uh eating away at the savings of kind of
the bottom fifty percent of the
population that don't have investment
assets
and kind of all that type of stuff um
the data is like pretty clear even
there's some papers like the imf
and things where uh the bottom
percentages of the socioeconomic ladder
like they experience much higher levels
of inflation than
the wealthier population and so when you
start to look at all of that you say
there is a world where
a deflationary or disinflationary
monetary policy would actually create a
more equitable world
now that doesn't mean that you get 100
benefit and no downside right so one of
the downsides is
inflation is supposed to uh engineer
growth and consumption and kind of all
of all of those things
but i think if you're optimizing for an
equitable world then
getting rid of that inflation ends up
being probably the number one
most important thing you could do it
literally trumps all
uh philanthropy kind of everything else
the second piece to it is i actually
think that
this idea of auditability and provable
scarcity and transparency and
decentralization and lack of control
it's just generally where the world's
going right so you talked a little bit
about like
you know what happens when the assets
actually have things coded into them
well if you understand how to read it
like you'll actually be able to audit
that
and it'll be transparently available
you'll understand like hey i'm giving my
data to this company and they can only
use it for x purpose
right and so we're moving more and more
to a world where
um it's less about like i just trust you
and it's much more i think people are
being
uh maybe not so far as cynical towards
organizations and institutions but
definitely
more about like prove it and kind of let
me audit let me see
um and so to me it's like less about
do i think it's gonna happen or not i
think like it's just the end game right
it's just gonna take a long time to get
there this is not like a one or two year
thing
okay okay so so i can summarize that
like you're excited about it
because of its potential to do good yes
okay but when
i know i'm only allowed one question go
ahead and get as many as you want this
is a word part for me
what's the most interesting like so that
that's all well and good but
like i said i'm a simple person so
what's the
interesting yet you know good moving the
peanut forward that you see happening
realistically in the next 24 months
oh i think right now what we're about to
see is the greatest
uh theft of wealth the
united states has ever seen simply from
uh
the three trillion dollars of
quantitative easing the manipulation of
interest rates
um and the way that i think about this
is uh
everything that's going on macroeconomic
wise uh we
saw 209 people ran for kind of inflation
hedge assets in general so
gold real estate all that kind of stuff
uh i think we're going to kind of see
that cycle play out again here
it's happening faster right so kind of
the government intervention happened
quicker it was a bigger
uh kind of step into the market um and
so
whether inflation kind of at a high
level happens or not it's more just like
the fear of
inflation forces people to move capital
into inflation hedge assets
and i think you kind of have that you
see you know the stanley drunken miller
is going on television saying five to
ten percent inflation
like whether he's right or not just
scares the hell out of people and so
they run
into inflation hedge assets um and so
for me it's
uh i personally believe
um the lack of financial education is
like a national emergency
right in terms of uh there's literally
people in the united states
and close to 50 of the population who
could not explain to you how
uh the money that they're saving in
their you know bank account
is actually worth less and less every
year like that's just a foreign concept
to them right they're like oh i have a
hundred dollars then i saved like
you know next year is worth a hundred
dollars yeah you're right and so they
eat just like that alone
i think is um somebody once said to me
we ask people to go to work so let's say
you're a teacher you're a fire
uh man or woman you're um a surgeon
uh or you you know you're a janitor
whatever your job is we ask you to go be
the best you can be at your job and then
we say oh by the way
in order to protect your wealth you also
have to be an investor
right so you can't just save the money
because it'll just get eroded away from
purchasing power standpoint
so we need you to go learn about stocks
or bonds or give you the money to
somebody else right and they'll
invest it for you or whatever um and so
the idea of bitcoin um there's this
saying in the bitcoin community like
it's a savings technology
so basically what you can do is rather
than save in dollars you just quote
save and just denominate in bitcoin and
then therefore
because it's a deflationary structure
with a disinflationary monetary schedule
uh basically it protects your wealth
right and so like
i think part of this is like when i say
all this stuff it's not lost on me that
there's a portion of people who are like
that sounds insane um
but i kind of think that's like where
the market gets made right is there's a
portion of people who think like
everything i just said makes a ton of
sense and like that's where the world's
headed
there's a ton of people who think that
guy's crazy and there's no way that's
gonna happen
um and like the market will ultimately
decide
right of like but have you seen anything
real that's going to um be
usable by the guy that doesn't
understand that the hundred dollars in
his bank account
next year or two years from now is
actually going to give him less
purchasing power
and provides a viable alternative for
him in the next 24 months
i'm gonna give you three data points
that uh
if you're not in it every day i think
this kind of surprises people
but they're like oh wait something's
going on here
last year in 2019 if you take the
annual transaction volumes on apple
venmo and paypal and you compare them to
what's called the
adjusted on-chain transaction volume so
we take away
take out all the exchanges take out all
of the
transactions to and from exchanges like
really trying to get
like what is the transaction volume on
the bitcoin network the bitcoin network
did
more annual volume last year than apple
pay power
uh venmo so a lot of people don't
realize that like
there's a lot of activity that actually
is occurring it's just not all happening
in the us in a consumer friendly type
application so
we don't think of it that way the second
data point
is um there's a gentleman named michael
saylor he's the
he's for 22 years he's been the ceo of a
publicly traded company
company's worth about 1.2 billion 1.3
billion dollar market cap
trade from the nasdaq he recently found
himself earlier this year with 500
million dollars of cash on his balance
sheet he's got a
business that throws off about 50
million dollars in ebitda annually
and uh he was worried about the macro
situation
and so over the last about eight to ten
weeks
he has taken 85 percent of that balance
sheet about 425 million dollars
and he has converted it to bitcoin and
publicly came out and said
i am going to use bitcoin as the reserve
asset on my
balance sheet because i believe that
every other asset i could put this
wealth into or this value has a negative
real return
and so again it's only one person but i
think that
um you know he basically is kind of like
breaking the damn
open and so i don't think everyone's
gonna go run and do it but does one guy
lead to
two to three to four right and so like
that's another kind of data point
of it's not the individual but it's a
corporate ceo
right so like he he's kind of paid to
think about this stuff
um but i think that's important and then
the third one is actually
uh the occ which you're probably more
familiar with than i am
uh brian brooks who's now the head of
the occ came from
coinbase which is the largest us-based
exchange
and um and he recently had a
clarification
that was issued so this isn't a new
ruling it was just kind of
clarified that banks are uh
legally allowed to custody crypto assets
along with all the other assets so a lot
of banks kind of hid behind
oh the occ hasn't given us clarification
we don't want to play this game so like
we're just not going to do anything
now that that is out there i think what
it does is it kind of opens the door for
some like m a
activity so does you know the jp morgans
of the world go buy a crypto exchange or
custody or something
and then two is like there will be some
forward thinking
banks that just say hey we're gonna
somehow build out
services for you know kind of digital
currencies whatever that looks like
and so i say all those data points as
like
each one individually probably doesn't
matter as much
right kind of like it's off on its own
when you start to put these together
i think it's just you're driving in the
right direction
we just don't know how long it takes to
get there how fast you're going that
type of stuff
super cool um so you can make a
different podcast of a dis like like a
the skeptic who does ignorance and
doesn't let ignorance stand in their way
asks dumb questions listen you you uh
my favorite part about the podcast is
that people come on and uh i learned
much more from them than they learned
from me but uh this is what makes it fun
right
i know this has been super fun for me
really appreciate it awesome lisa where
can people find you on the internet or
find out more about feistman
uh www.com and they can find me on
linkedin
uh slash lisa was here lisa was here
oh how did you get that i don't know it
was the first like lisa s was already
taken
and so anybody can have any vanity url
you want on linkedin still it's the
last vanity opportunity left on the
internet i love that
okay thank you so much for doing this we
definitely will have to do this again in
the future yeah really appreciate it
lovely talking to you